[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Anne
gellineck guten Abend in diesen Tagen
sind wir alle Israelis sagte Annalena
berbock die deutsche Außenministerin
heute in der Nähe des Gazastreifens sie
appellierte an die radikal islamische
Hamas und ihre Verbündeten die
verschleppten Geiseln freizulassen und
musste in Tel Aviv wie viele Israelis
wegen luftalarms kurzfristig einen
Schutzraum aufsuchen unterdessen
bereitet die israelische Armee offenbar
weiter eine Bodenoffensive vor
israelische Soldaten und Panzer haben
erste Einsätze im Gazastreifen
durchgeführt um nach Hinweisen auf die
verschleppten zu suchen Luk walpot
berichtet von einem Tag voller
Anspannung Gaza heute früh auf
Flugblättern und per SMS fordert Israel
die Bewohner auf auf die stadtrichtung
Süden zu evakuieren in 24 Stunden der
Norden des Streifens ist jetzt
Kriegsgebiet jenseits des Zauns macht
sich Israels Armee bereit für einen
Einmarsch und Israels Partner sind
persönlich gekommen um noch einmal ihre
Unterstützung zu bekräftigen
US-Verteidigungsminister Austin
verspricht
Militärhilfe es gibt nie eine
Rechtfertigung für Terrorismus erst
recht nicht bei diesen
der
Hamas die Luftangriffe auf Gaza halten
derweil an und Hamas antwortet weiter
mit Raketen in Richtung Tel Aviv
mittendrin die deutsche Außenministerin
inetti nah dem Gazastreifen Israels
Sicherheit sagt sie ist für Deutschland
staatsresung die Details der grausamen
Hamas Terrorattacken das Leid der Opfer
all das ist schwer zu ertragen wir
fühlen mit denjenigen die die geliebte
Menschen verloren haben oder immer noch
um das Leben ihrer Liebsten Bang ihr
Schicksal lässt uns keine
Ruhe israel habe das Recht und die
Pflicht sich im Rahmen des
internationalen Rechts gegen diesen
brutalen barbarischen Terror zu wehren
israel hat unsere umfassende
Solidarität und Israel hat unsere volle
Unterstützung die Hamas ist mit ihrem
Terror auf Israel ganz allein für diese
furchtbare Lage verantwortlich Terror
zur Mobilisierung der Straße das Kalkül
der Hamas in Jericho tulkarem in Nablus
im Westjordanland kommt es nach dem
Freitagsgebet zu blutigen Protesten
gegen die israelische Besatzung Bilanz Z
Tote und immer wieder Luftalarm Europas
Spitzenpolitikerinnen kommissionschefin
von derlin und Parlamentspräsidentin
metzola müssen bei ihren Gesprächen mit
den israelischen Partnern kurzzeitig
Schutz suchen Europa sagt von derlin
später im Gespräch mit Regierungschef
Netanyahu stehe in dieser schweren
Stunde an Israels Seite wir müssen jetzt
noch enger mit Israel und den Ländern in
der Region zusammenarbeiten für
Stabilität gegen
Terror Terror den diese deutschen
Familien hautnah zu spüren bekommen ihre
Angehörigen werden vermisst wie die
22-Jährige shaniny Luk von Hamas
verschleppt und jetzt mit
Kopfverletzungen als Geisel in einem
Krankenhaus in Gaza ihem mutterhoft auf
Freilassung jetzt stellen Sie sich vor
im gaserstreifen im Krankenhaus wo
drumrum bombardiert wird und kein Strom
vielleicht kein Wasser in den
Verhältnissen ich weiß nicht wie schwer
verletzt s Rose ist also von dem her ist
die Zeit GPP einzelne Patrouillen
israelischer Soldaten heißt es am Abend
hätten bereits Erkundungen jenseits des
Grenzzauns
unternommen über soziale Medien hatte
die Hamas für heute zum Tag des
aufgerufen zum Protest der arabischen
Welt gegen Israels Vorgehen in Gaza und
weltweit folgten Muslime diesem Aufruf
meist nach dem traditionellen
Freitagsgebet die Furcht vor
Ausschreitungen war groß allein in
Bagdad gingen ztausende auf die Straßen
und skandierten Israel feindliche
Parolen in Jordanien das diplomatische
Beziehungen zu Israel unterhält gingen
ebenfalls Tausende auf die Straßen
Sicherheitskräfte versuchen versuchten
die Demonstrationen
aufzulösen unsere Korrespondentin goline
atai ist in den Libanon gereist in
Israels Nachbarland im Norden dort
herrscht die Israel feindliche Hisbollah
Miliz die den Terrorangriff der Hamas
begeistert gefeiert hatte guten Abend
goline nach
Beirut wie haben Sie heute den Tag in
Beirut erlebt und wie groß ist die
Gefahr dass die hisbolla Israel von
Norden her
angreift
ein bisschen fühlt sich das so an wie
die Ruhe vor dem Sturm für viele
Libanesen es ist wirklich eine deutliche
Anspannung eine deutliche Nervosität
hier zu erleben es kam heute wieder zu
einem Schlagabtausch an der
libanesisch-israelischen Grenze die
hisbolla hat israelische Stellungen
angegriffen das sind in den letzten
Tagen bislang kleinere Gefechte gewesen
also es kocht nicht es köchelt aber es
lässt wirklich die Nervosität ansteigen
es sind bislang drei dollerkämpfer ums
Leben gekommen und heute haben wir auch
gehört dass in Kameramann der
Nachrichtenagentur Reus an der Grenze
getötet wurde also jede Seite in diesem
Konflikt schaut ganz nervös auf die
andere Seite es scheint als ob niemand
eine Regionalisierung dieses Krieges
möchte aber alle Positionen die diese
Seiten vertreten deuten darauf hin dass
es eine solche Regionalisierung geben
könnte ob es eine Kettenreaktion gibt
das hängt davon ab ob es eine
Bodenoffensive der israelischen Streit
Streitkräfte gibt im gazaastreifen ob es
zu einem Existenzkampf der Hammers kommt
das haben wir heute in bairut deutlich
an zwei Äußerungen gemerkt einmal der
stellvertretende Hisbollah Chef der
gesagt hat wir stehen bereit wir schauen
zu was da passiert wir lassen uns auch
nicht gut zureden von den Vereinten
Nationen oder von den USA wir
entscheiden selbst wann wir in den Kampf
ziehen und der iranische Außenminister
der gestern Nacht hier in birut war und
noch mal ganz klar und ganz deutlich
gesagt hat wenn es zu weiteren
Kriegsverbrechen gaserstreifen kommen
würde so wörtlich dann bestüe die
Möglichkeit dass weitere Fronten
eröffnet werden und wenn ich dann noch
höre von Libanesen dass Schutzräume
geschaffen werden im Südlibanon wenn ich
dann noch höre dass an der
syrisch-israelischen Grenze an auf der
syrischen Seite Kämpfer mobilisiert
werden Milizen mobilisiert werden dann
weiß ich dass es sich nicht um leere
Drohungen handelt sie werden das weiter
für uns beobachten vielen Dank goline
atai war das live aus dem im
Libanon obwohl die Hamas also weltweit
zu Protesten aufgerufen hatte blieb es
in Deutschland relativ ruhig es gab
kleinere
proalästinensische Demonstrationen in
einigen deutschen Städten die teilweise
von der Polizei aufgelöst wurden dennoch
geht die Bundesregierung von einer
erhöhten Gefährdungslage besonders für
jüdischeer Einrichtungen aus der
Konflikt ist also längst in Deutschland
angekommen Dominik mülller hat Stimmen
der arabischen und der jüdischen
Community
eingefangen heute Nachmittag Berlin
Neuköln rund 150 Menschen haben sich
versammelt trotz Demonstrationsverbots
aufgeheizte Stimmung immer wieder alakb
rufen nach einer Weile löst die Polizei
die Ansammlung auf die Sorge ist groß
auch weil die Hamas weltweit zu Gewalt
aufgerufen
hat heute Mittag in der Beit und nasser
Moschee in Köln das freitagsgebiet
schockiert waren viele
Gemeindemitglieder als sie letztes
Wochenende den Überfall der Hamas auf
Israel mitbekommen haben nun beten Sie
für Frieden und lauschen den Worten des
Imams Mahmud Ahmad
Mali Brüder und schwest sie haben enge
Verbindungen und Partnergemeinden in den
Palästinensergebieten und in Israel der
Angriff die Rechtfertigungsversuche und
mancherlei Reaktionen verstören sie
terorgruppe oder Extremisten sagen so im
Namen Gottes oder im Namen dieser
Religion haben wir das gemacht oder wir
feiern das das das tut weh ich habe in
den Medien gelesen dass teilweise
Muslime gezeigt worden sind die das
ganze bejubeln und ich würde mich freuen
wenn man auch zeigt dass Muslime trauern
gerade für ihre jüdischen Mitbürger und
dass man an einer Lösung arbeitet und
eine Lösung findet wie man diesen
Konflikt lösen muss Frieden wünschen
sich auch viele der Menschen im Essener
Norden im Ruhrgebiet etliche haben
Wurzeln im Nahen Osten oder der Türkei
in dem Konflikt stehen viele an der
Seite ihrer
Glaubensbrüder der Islam ist unser
Glaube und da ist immer eine Verbindung
dazwischen auch wenn palästiner Türken
Syrer oder so da ist immer Freundschaft
dazwischen Brüderlichkeit wir haben den
gleichen glauben wir glauben an den
gleichen Gott vor allem auch aus
arabischen Quellen informieren sich
viele Menschen hier über den Krieg auch
Emin den Überfall der Hamas müsse man im
Zusammenhang betrachten sagt ihr
Zusammenhang mit der Unterdrückung des
palästinensischen Volkes in
Gaza es ist keine schöne Art und Weise
das stimmt dazu sage ich nichts aber wie
ich gerade gesagt habe es ist einfach
eine Gegenreaktion wenn man z.B das
beachtet dass daavor halt Kinder getötet
wurden dann Wert man sich ja natürlich
und dann ist es auf eine Art und Weise
gerecht aber es ist nicht schön jüdische
Gemeindemitglieder in Düsseldorf
fürchten um ihre Sicherheit dieser Tage
noch mehr als sonst heute am Tag desalt
Aufrufs der Hamas haben sie entschieden
ihre Kipper ihre Kopfbedeckung dennoch
zu tragen so demonstrativ wie selten wir
wollen also mit diese kleine Aktion
einfach allen zeigen dass man keine
Angst haben muss also Terroristen
radikale Antisemiten haben einfach
keinen Platz bei uns ein großer Wunsch
ein sie mit unzähligen Muslimen in
Deutschland das Frieden herrscht und
niemand mehr sterben muss im Nahen
Osten und hier geht's weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Hanna Zimmermann und die
beginnen mit einer Tat die wohl auch mit
der Lage im Nahen Osten zu tun hat ja
ganz genau bei einem Messerangriff in
einer Schule im Norden Frankreichs ist
ein Lehrer getötet worden zwei weitere
Personen wurden schwer verletzt am Abend
wurde nun die landesweite
Alarmbereitschaft erhöht in Minister
damaner sagte der Anschlag steht
zweifellos im Zusammenhang mit den
Geschehnissen im Nahen Osten seit
Samstag seien 12 Personen mit Waffen in
der Nähe von Schul festgesetzt worden
auch der mutmaßliche Täter in Aras wurde
festgenommen soll sich um einen
ehemaligen Schüler mit tchenischen
Wurzeln Handeln der als Gefährder
geführt und erst gestern kontrolliert
wurde Frankreichs Präsident macron
verurteilte die Tat vor Ort als
islamistischen
Terror nordkorea hat Russland nach
Angaben der USA militärische Ausrüstung
und Munition für den Angriffskrieg gegen
die Ukraine geliefert und zwar mehr als
1000 Container so das Weiße Haus man
gehe davon aus dass pjyang von Moskau im
Gegenzug hochentwickelte russische
Waffentechnologien wolle um das
nordkoreanische Atomprogramm auszubauen
dies werde genau
beobachtet bei einem schweren
Verkehrsunfall eines schleuserfahrzeugs
sind im Südosten Bayerns sieben
geflüchtete ums Leben gekommen darunter
auch ein Kind 16 weitere wurden zum Teil
schwer verletzt der mutmaßliche
Schleuser verlor auf der A4
die Kontrolle über seinen
Kleintransporter als er sich einer
Polizeikontrolle entziehen wollte gegen
ihn wird unter anderem wegen eines
Tötungsdelikts ermittelt mit 23 Personen
war das Fahrzeug völlig
überladen zur Asylpolitik nach der
zweitägigen
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz haben die
Länder klare Forderungen an den Bund
formuliert neben deutlich mehr Geld für
die Versorgung von geflüchteten seinen
schnellere Asylverfahren nötig diese
sollten laut hessens Ministerpräsident
Rhein bei Menschen mit geringer
Bleibeperspektive nur dre Monate dauern
die Länder forderten in ihrer
Abschlusserklärung zudem eine bundesweit
einheitliche Bezahlkarte für geflüchtete
und das Abschiebungen erleichtert
werden es hat sich was verschoben in
Deutschland das merken die
Ministerpräsidenten der Länder wie eben
gesehen und das merken vor allem die
Kommunen die dafür zuständig sind
Flüchtlinge unterzubringen auch solche
Gemeinden die sich immer stark gemacht
hatten für die Aufnahme von
Asylbewerbern jetzt ist die Frage nach
der Obergrenze wieder da der Ruf nach
Kontrolle und nach schärferen Regeln und
seit dem Erstarken der AFD bei den
Wahlen in Hessen und Bayern ist das
Thema nun auch ganz oben in der Politik
angekommen der Kanzler lut am Abend
Oppositionsführer Friedrich märz und
zwei Ministerpräsidenten zum Gespräch
Thema eine neue Asylpolitik ich habe
kurz vor der Sendung mit Friedrich Merz
gesprochen zuvor aber zeigt uns Eva
Schiller den Alltag eines abgekämpften
Oberbürgermeisters er will uns zeigen
wie seine Willkommenskultur zerbröselt
deshalb nimmt uns Richard Arnold mit auf
einen Spaziergang durch schwäbisch
gmündt n Retter von allen ja und wir
sollen erst mal eigentlich auf uns
gucken und auf unser vololg und dann
sieht man weiter mit der Ukraine dann
mit Israel oder so wir mischen uns
überall ein wo es uns eigentlich ein
Scheißdreck auf Deutsch angeht
Alarmsignal für den CDU
Oberbürgermeister die Stimmen derer die
sich für geflüchtete engagieren was
liegt gerade an was macht euch Sorge
Sorge wo zieht man da die Grenze wo
zieht man Grenz sagt okay den geht
wirklich schlecht oder die suchen nur
hier in Deutschland das bequeme Leber
sind fr wahrscheinlich über jeden wo
herkmt aber andersrum soll die was dabei
zu beitragen und da mag ich aber auch
dass halt die Erwartungen sehr hoch sind
dass man hier was kriegt an sich keine
neuen Töne für schwäbischmündt schon die
Stadt muss dabeispiel für gelingende
Integration engagierte Ehrenamtliche die
extra ein Flüchtlingsboot hergekaht
haben als Mahnmal für Menschlichkeit
Merkels wir schaffen das hier wurde es
in die Tat umgesetzt jetzt sagt der
Bürgermeister wir schaffen das nicht
mehr wenn immer mehr Menschen kommen
dann ist es nicht möglich sich diesen
Menschen zu widmen und dann sind auch
die Bürger frustriert denn ein
Oberbürgermeister kann mit seinem
Rathaus nicht alleine integrieren da
braucht es dann natürlich immer eine
aktive Bürgerschaft das schaffen wir
dann nicht mehr werden frustriert die
wenden sich ab er nimmt uns mit ins
willkommencenter umgewandelt in eine
Jobbörse nur es kommen zu wenige von 760
erwerbsfähigen Ukrainern arbeitenade
die Mens das ist doch zu wenig in
Deutschland sind es nur 18% in Polen zi
Drittel in den Niederlanden und in
Dänemark über 70% die Anreize sind
falsch gesetzt nicht der der nichts tut
soll belohnt werden sondern der der sich
einbringt und der arbeitet nebenan
sitzen drei junge syrische Ärzte die
seit eineinhalb Jahren um die
Anerkennung ihrer Abschlüsse kämpfen zur
Überbrückung ein freiwilliges soziales
Jahr machen deutsche Gründlichkeit
Deutschland das Land der Träume und so
ich wollte immer hier als Arzt arbeiten
jetzt bin ich hier ich habe die Sprache
schon gelernt aber ich habe keine
Gelegenheit als Arzt hier zu arbeiten es
ist wirklich
frustrierend ich mache noch weiter das
Recht und die Pflicht zu arbeiten das
fordern Sie hier in schwäbischmünt aber
so realistisch ist Bürgermeister Arnold
auch wie Deutschlands überlastete
Behörden Arbeit für alle Einwanderer
organisieren sollen das bleibt die
FR und frisch aus dem Treffen im
Kanzleramt ist uns der Oppositionsführer
und CDU Vorsitzende Friedrich März jetzt
zugeschaltet guten Abend Herr März guten
Abend fr sie haben ja vor dem Treffen
gesagt sie wollten sich auf keine faulen
Kompromisse einlassen bei diesem
Gespräch worauf haben Sie sich denn
eingelassen ich will zunächst einmal
sagen dass das atmosphärisch ein sehr
gutes Gespräch war und dass wir den
Eindruck mitgenommen haben dass der
Bundes kanzer jetzt wirklich ernsthaft
über die Begrenzung des Zuzugs nach
Deutschland sprechen will wir das waren
ja bekanntlich
neben dem Bundeskanzler der häsische
Ministerpräsident Boris Rhein und der
niedersächsische Ministerpräsident
Stefan weil also wir haben in einer
guten Atmosphäre gesprochen und wir sind
uns im Ziel einig ob wir uns auf dem Weg
einig werden das werden die nächsten
Tage und Wochen zeigen bei welchen
Maßnahmen gehen sie denn mit und welche
finden Sie äh nicht angemessen na ja
umgekehrt die Regierung muss sagen bei
welchen Maßnahmen sie mitgeht ich glaube
es kommt zunächst einmal darauf an dass
wir in dem wichtigsten Ausländergesetz
das wir in Deutschland haben nämlich dem
aufenthalsgesetz
äh wieder eine Passage aufnehmen die vor
einigen Wochen gestrichen worden ist
nämlich dass der Zuzug nach Deutschland
begrenzt wird nicht nur gesteuert
sondern begrenzt wird die Worte und
Begrenzung sind gestrichen worden die
müssen da wieder rein das ist sozusagen
das was vor die Klammer gehört und dann
müssen wir uns über die Maßnahmen
unterhalten da wird es eine ganze Reihe
geben ich habe den Bundeskanzler ein
zweieinhalbseitiges Positionspapier von
uns übergeben mit insgesamt 16 Maßnahmen
allein für die deutsche Innenpolitik die
wir jetzt ergreifen müssten nach unserem
Dafürhalten und darüber wird die
Bundesregierung jetzt sprechen und wir
haben uns verabredet dass wir in Kürze
widersprechen miteinander um zu schauen
ob wir hier einen gemeinsamen Weg finden
wie gesagt im Ziel sind wir uns offenbar
einig gucken wir mal auf ein paar
Maßnahmen die ja auch im migrationspaket
Stehen gucken wir mal auf die
Abschiebung diese K ja jetzt mit mehr
Härte durchgesetzt werden aber die
Wahrheit ist ja dass nur ein ganz
geringer Teil der Menschen die kein
Bleiberecht in Deutschland haben auch
wirklich abgeschoben werden können
nämlich nur ungefähr 20.000 alle anderen
werden geduldet weil in ihrem Land Krieg
ist weil sie krank sind weil sie keine
Papiere haben weil das Land sie nicht
zurücknimmt das heißt eigentlich dass
die Verschärfung der ab abschieberegeln
überhaupt nicht bringt na überhaupt
nichts bringen soweit würde ich nicht
gehen Frau gell es bringt nicht so sehr
viel und deswegen en habe ich auch Wert
darauf gelegt dass wir nicht nur über
die Frage miteinander sprechen wie wir
diejenigen behandeln die jetzt schon
hier sind sondern das viel größere
Problem ist der unverändert sehr hohe
Zuzug wir haben in diesem Jahr schon
deutlich über 200.000 neue Anträge auf
Asyl bekommen die Zahlen müssen runter
wir gehen in diesem Jahr auf über
300.000 und das ist einfach zu viel also
wir müssen jetzt sehr viel mehr sprechen
über die Frage wie begrenzen wir den
Zuzug und da liegt der Teufel im Detail
aber wie begrenzen wir den Zuzug Frage
gebe ich an Sie zurück na ja also indem
wir zunächst einmal auch äh vom
Bundeskanzler erwarten dass ja hier eine
klare Erklärung abgibt dass das so nicht
weitergehen kann wie in der
Vergangenheit und dass wir uns dann ganz
konkret über Maßnahmen unterhalten z.B
über sichere Herkunftsländer da haben
die Ministerpräsidenten einen
interessanten Vorschlag gemacht über den
können wir gerne reden aber auch z.B
über die Frage wie Asylverfahren schon
an den Außengrenzen stattfinden bevor
diese Menschen überhaupt nach
Deutschland kommen insbesondere dann
wenn sie keinen Asylgrund haben das sind
natürlich Dinge über die in Europa und
Deutschland seit Jahren gesprochen wird
die Kommunen beschweren sich auch schon
seit vielen Jahren über zu viele
Flüchtlinge und jetzt kommt wohl
aufgrund der Wahlerfolge der AFD
Bewegung in die Politik warum lassen Sie
sich von den Populisten in dieser
Debatte treiben wir lassen uns gar nicht
treiben im Gegenteil wir haben das was
wir heute
unter die gemeinsame Überschrift
gestellt haben nämlich Humanität und
Ordnung in der asyl- und
Flüchtlingspolitik zur gemeinsamen
Überschrift gemacht was wir schon vor
über einem halben Jahr in einem
beschlusspapier der Bundestagsfraktion
zum Ausdruck gebracht haben also ich
stelle fest dass insbesondere die
Sozialdemokraten nach diesen
verheerenden Wahlergebnissen vom letzten
Sonntag jetzt offensichtlich erkannt
haben dass hier Lösungen notwendig sind
ich will das ausdrücklich begrüßen dass
hier zumindest der Bundeskanzler und die
Sozialdemokraten sich auf uns zubewegen
und wir hier tatsächlich gemeinsam zu
Lösungen kommen könnten mehr kann ich
heute abend nicht sagen letzte Frage zu
ihrer eigenen Partei sie haben ja immer
wieder drastische Formulierungen gewählt
um in der Debatte zu punkten Stichwort
zahnersatzt ihr Parteifreund in Hessen
Boris rin der heute Abend auch dabei war
setzt ja eher auf die sanfte Tour ist
die Methode März letzten Sonntag
abgewählt worden nein Frau gellineek im
Gegenteil und Boris rein hat am Montag
mit mir zusammen in einer
Pressekonferenz es war gesagt es war
genauso richtig und wir haben durch
diese Zuspitzung auch noch zusätzliche
Zustimmung bekommen das war in Berlin im
Februar so und das war jetzt im Oktober
auch in Hessen so das war die Sichtweise
von Friedrich Merz auf das Gespräch mit
dem Kanzler und das Thema Migration das
uns wohl erstmal erhalten bleibt vielen
Dank nach Berlin ich danke
Ihnen ein Abkommen mit Polen um das
durchwinken von Flüchtlingen Richtung
Deutschland zu verhindern könnte auch
ein Baustein bei der Kontrolle von
Migration sein der Zeitpunkt allerdings
ist äußerst ungünstig in Polen wird am
Sonntag gewählt und die regierende
peaceepartei tut alles um Stimmung zu
machen gegen Flüchtlinge gegen die EU
und vor allem gegen Deutschland doch
seit ein paar Wochen scheint ein Sieg
der peace nicht mehr unbedingt
ausgemacht die oppositionelle
Bürgerplattform mit proeuropäer Donald
Tusk an der Spitze liegt in den Umfragen
an zweiter Stelle und könnte mit einer
Koalition einen Machtwechsel
herbeiführen nichts ist sicher nur eins
Polen steht vor einer Richtungswahl
Natalie Steger
berichtet önig hätte ein Geschenk für
sie sagt der nationalkonservative
Regierungspolitiker so eine Fahne mit
der sie sich gut identifizieren können
der Abgeordnete der Opposition empört
was wie slapstig rüber kommt steht für
den zugespitzten Wahlkampf der Regierung
die Opposition wird als Befehlsempfänger
der deutschen
dargestellt auch von Peace parteichf
Jaros Kinski im gesamten Wahlkampf wie
besessen von Deutschland seinl
ab wir regieren Polen selbst ohne Berlin
ohne
Moskau wollt ihr einen ST nach der Art
von Donald Tusk nein skandieren seine
Anhänger und nach Berlin nach Berlin zum
Slogan Richtung Tusk
geworden flankiert wird das von der
Propaganda des staatlichen Fernsehens
die proeutsche Mission TuS steht da der
Oppositionsführer sei längst eine
Marionette Berlins
it Tusk der schon als euatspräsident
Polens Souveränität beschädigt habe so
auch Ministerpräsident
morwi wie er Angela Merkel schmeichelte
sich an ihren Rock klammerte für mich
als Pole war es absolut peinlich und
traurig dass er sich ihrem Willen so
unterordnet Donald Tusk ist der
politische Ehemann von Angela
Merkel schimpfte liegt mit seinen
liberalkonservativen zwar hinter der
peace aber es könnte für eine
Regierungskoalition reichen mit einem
linken und einem konservativen Bündnis
Tusk will das Verhältnis zu Brüssel
reparieren in Polen die politische
Kontrolle über Medien und Justiz
zurückdrehen wir haben Taus Gründe um
sauer zu sein oder sogar
wütend wir haben tausend Gründe um diese
verdorbene und korrupte klicke von der
Macht zu trennen
und dann gibt es noch die ultrarechte
europakritische konfederatiia der
einzige mögliche peace
Koalitionspartner wir wollen nicht dass
in Polen die Abtreibung legalisiert wird
wir sind gegen die Realisierung der
marxistischen kulturellen Agenda also
die LGBT Bewegung gegen alles
wokeer es ist eine Schicksalswahl am
Sonntag die wichtigste seit
1989 darin sind sich die verfeindeten
Lager tatsächlich einmal einig das ist
dann aber auch das einzige in diesem
hochpolarisierten Polen das Rennen ist
noch völlig
offen und hier geht's jetzt weiter mit
den Nachrichten zunächst aus der
Wirtschaft und mit Hanna Zimmermann
schon lange wird in der EU über den
Einsatz des
unkrautvernichtungsmittels Glyphosat
gestritten heute haben nun die EU-Länder
darüber abgestimmt ob die Zulassung des
Mittels verlängert wird Valerie Haller
allerdings gab es dabei keine Einigung
was bedeutet das jetzt genau das
bedeutet der Streit geht mitte November
in die nächste Runde und scheitert dann
die Einigung wieder ist die
EU-Kommission am Zug und sie hatte eine
zulassungsverlängerung um weitere 10
Jahre schon vorgeschlagen Brüssel stützt
sich auf eine Untersuchung der
Europäischen Behörde für
Lebensmittelsicherheit die sowörtlich
keine inakzeptablen Gefahren in dem
Unkrautvernichter sieht aber
gleichzeitig auf da enlücken hinweist
kritiker halten Glyphosat für
krebserregend und eine Gefahr für die
Artenvielfalt wo es versprüht wird
wächst kein Gras kein Strauch kein Moos
für den glyphosaththersteller Bayer ist
die nächste Abstimmung ein wichtiger
Termin denn für das Unternehmen steht
einiges auf dem Spiel was würde denn für
ein mögliches Verbot für den Hersteller
Bayer ganz genau bedeuten also rein
wirtschaftlich wäre ein Verbot für Bayer
wohl verkraftbar weil Europa beim
glyphosatabsatz ein verhält mäßig
kleiner Markt ist nach Nord und
Südamerika Verkauf Bayer weit größere
Mengen aber fürs Image kann es nicht gut
sein wenn das Mittel in Europa verboten
wird zumal Bayer ja immer noch mit
Klagen in den USA konfrontiert ist
manche Prozesse hat der Konzern gewonnen
in anderen Fällen musste er hohe Summen
zahlen vielen Dank Valerie für diese
Einordnungen laut einer neuen Studie
haben sich die deutschleistungen von
neun kläsler deut verschlechtert das
zeigt der neue bildungstrend im Auftrag
der
Kultusministerkonferenz etwa jeder
dritte neunklässler verfehlte demnach im
Fach Deutsch beim Lesen und beim
Hörverständnis die Standards für den
mittleren Schulabschluss als Grund wird
unter anderem der Unterrichtsausfall
durch die coronapandemie genannt besser
geworden sind die Schüler in Englisch
was wiederum auf eine vermehrte Nutzung
von digitalen Medien auf Englisch
zurückgeführt
wird immer weniger Menschen in
Deutschland essen täglich Wurst oder
Fleisch nur noch jeder fünfte das geht
aus dem ernährungsrepport 2023 hervor
den bundesernährungsminister östem mir
vorgestellt hat 10% greifen mittlerweile
täglich zu veganen oder vegetarischen
Alternativen zudem gaben
57% der Befragten an darauf zu achten
dass die Lebensmittel preiswert sind ein
Plus von 10% gegenüber dem Vorjahr
und das war's von uns hier geht's jetzt
weiter mit Olli welke und der heuteshow
und gegen 0:25 Uhr begrüßt Sie hier
Christopher wermann mit unserem heute
journal Update Ihnen noch einen schönen
Freitagabend trotz allem bis morgen
[Musik]
tschüss guten Abend dieser Freitag
brachte Rekorde noch nie war es seit
Beginn regelmäßiger Wetteraufzeichnung
in Deutschland
1881 so spät im Jahr so warm wie heute
und noch nie gab es so spät im Jahr noch
mal einen heißen Tag einen Tag mit
Temperaturen über 30° wie in Müllheim
und in Rheinfelden dahinter steckte ein
Tief das aus Südwesteuropa noch mal die
warme Luft heranführte jetzt aber wird
sich das Wetter komplett ändern denn
eine Kaltfront bringt in Schüben
deutlich kühl külere Luft heran die
Kaltfront liegt um Mitternacht etwa
zwischen dem niederrein und femahn vor
der Kaltfront kommt der Wind noch aus
südwestlichen dahinter aus
nordwestlichen Richtungen an der Nordsee
erwarten wir schwere sturmböhen und im
Harz sogar Orkanböhen mit dieser
Kaltfront gibt's kräftige Regenfälle zum
Teil sind die mit Gewittern durchsetzt
klar ist das dagegen hier im Südosten
die Nachttemperaturen liegen zwischen 18
und 9° und morgen übertag wird's kaum
wärmer unds erwarten 12 bis
22° morgen gibt's schon wieder neue
kräftige Schauer und Gewitter von der
Nordsee dann aber wechseln Sonne und
Wolken zwischen dem niederrein und der
oder freundlich ab und die Kaltfront
wird weiter nach Süden ziehen und wird
dann am Nachmittag auch wieder mal die
Sonne am Main durchlassen davor aber
regnet es noch kräftig zum Teil mit
Gewittern am Sonntag ist es dann sehr
kühl und wechselhaft bei 7 bis 15° die
neue Woche startet kühl aber doch
deutlich trockener guten
Abend